JANE: Hi, everyone.
So our project is
called Mini Worlds.
So basically, we want
to view this video game
where you can build your world
with Kinect by just grabbing
things and build them
by dropping them.
So the idea is you can go
into this 3-D environment
to design your own
home and your own room.
So my name is Jane.
So I'm from Course 3 and
I'm a graduate student.
CATTLEYA: I am Cattleya, I am
Course 6 undergrad student,
class of 2019.
So we address this
problem of when
we try to create our own world,
as Jane has already introduced.
So we then come up with a
word game called Media World.
And we will show
you our demo now.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
JANE: So Cattleya will
be controlling the game
and I will be doing here.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
JANE: So I hope it's
not capturing me.
PROFESSOR: You may
want to restart.
JANE: Yeah, we will restart.
PROFESSOR: There's going to
be technical difficulties.
One of the [INAUDIBLE]
presentation [INAUDIBLE]..
JANE: OK.
So now we are trying to
locate ourself in our home.
PROFESSOR: Move a little closer.
JANE: Could it be it is
capturing other people?
MARK VRABLIC: I mean
you can check for this.
CATTLEYA: Yeah, maybe.
I think so.
It's [INAUDIBLE]
JANE: Yeah, I think
it's not tracking her.
So--
STUDENT: Do you have
the [INAUDIBLE]??
JANE: Yes.
MARK VRABLIC: You
should pull that out.
I don't know how [INAUDIBLE]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
JANE: OK.
So somehow, we just got indoor.
Because we saw a house and we
just went through that door
to go into your room.
And your getting all
of you to your yard.
PROFESSOR: So how are
you switching rooms?
CATTLEYA: We changed the scene.
We can disable it right now.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
CATTLEYA: To a wider problem.
[INAUDIBLE]
JANE: So what we just did is
that we deleted that door.
So cannot go indoor and now
you can travel more freely
in your yard, not
through just that door.
CATTLEYA: We tried to
really show you the thing,
how to like--
we can choose the material
and then choose the object
to paint into [INAUDIBLE].
Then you can [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, sorry.
[INAUDIBLE] low
position if you delete.
So that we-- here, you
will see [INAUDIBLE] oh.
We can also rotate thing
around, I can show you.
JANE: So the only
problem here is
it's a little bit hard
to control things.
But we will get there.
[APPLAUSE]
CATTLEYA: Let me show you.
Now, we will get rid of
all the stuff we have build
and we will try to build
from the scratch for you.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
JANE: So we just
deleted the yard
and you want to
locate yourself again.
No-- oh, yeah.
Here.
Good.
CATTLEYA: Now, we have
to grab some object here.
And then--
JANE: And you can
create that object.
CATTLEYA: And then you can
create it by raising your hand.
AUDIENCE: What?
[LAUGHTER]
You can delete it by
lower your hand down.
Also, now I will try
to do the rotation.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
[INAUDIBLE]
JANE: I think that's fine.
PROFESSOR: This is an
operation [INADUCIBLE]..
JANE: OK.
CATTLEYA: OK.
So now, you can create a bridge.
And you can grab it and
rotate it around like this.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
CATTLEYA: Another thing that you
can control this, the camera.
If you wanted to, maybe you
can do something like this or--
and so now like this.
Also, if you want
to rotate a camera,
you can [INAUDIBLE]
move body like this.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
Do we have any questions?
AUDIENCE: How are
you so amazing?
[LAUGHTER]
CATTLEYA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: What were the--
what's the role did
you use to establish
what kind of protocols?
Were there some kind
of preformatted roles
that connect, or did you
all just do that scratch?
JANE: Oh.
So for the Kinect,
our TA have already
made the script that
allow us to keep track
of the coordinate
in 3D of our hands
and the other joints like hips.
And what I do is that we--
I implement-- For example,
the zoom in and zoom out.
I implement that if
your right hand is
behind your right shoulder
for a certain amount,
you will got zoom out.
And if it--
I think it's the C
direction, C index.
If it more than
your shoulder, it
will go to zoom in like that.
PROFESSOR: So they build a
lot of their own intervals
based on x and y
and z coordinates.
So any gesture that
she was doing she
actually programmed just
based on plain logical rules
about where two
points in space are.
MARK VRABLIC: So you
train it beforehand.
And then I'm curious whether
if you had another Kinect,
it'd be more
responsive if you had
one in the front and the back.
That really makes the sensors
twenty one mega sense.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
MARK VRABLIC: That's going
to be hard to implement,
but yes, theoretically,
it would be better.
People do do it.
It'd be a lot of math to
get the two to match up.
Also, there are [INAUDIBLE]
camera who probably started
to render at each other.
Okay.
JANE: Question?
AUDIENCE: Have you had Unity
experience before this class?
JANE: I have a little bit.
But yes, but learn
from this class a lot.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: And what about Kinect?
JANE: No, it never happened.
Yes.
PROFESSOR: Any other questions?
All right.
Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]